Okay, welcome back. Welcome to video
three. Well done. You survived video two.
Now, we're going to take what we learnt in
video two and really start applying it to
the real world. Now, how do we start
applying this to the real world? Well,
these principles that we've been through
in video two, essentially what we're going
to do is try and take the professional
trader approach, which is always,
starting with downloading data from the
world that is publicly and freely
available and downloading that data into
Excel. Now, why is that important? Well,
we're going to kill two birds with one
stone here, actually, because what we're
going to do is download data for S&P 500,
sterling US dollar, euro US dollar, all of
the major forex pairs and indices,
essentially. And the first thing you're
going to see is that
over specific time horizons, you'll see
that what retail traders do, what bad
retail traders do, the guys who always
lose money, they trade these instruments
and trade them in a way where they
actually consistently lose money because
they're doing the opposite of what
professional traders do, which is
consistently make money.
And the second thing you're going to see
really is how to do that process, how you
go through that process to actually go
into the world, get the data, download it,
manipulate it in Excel.
So you're on top of the data and you
understand the market that you're about to
enter and what the opportunities are in
terms of available opportunities to make
money over time horizons in that market.
Now, once you understand that, you'll
start really understanding why
professional traders take the opposite
approach to retail traders, because this
is really the first thing that you would
learn as a professional trader, as in
going into the world and getting data.
Why's data are important? Because data
tells you your opportunities in any given
market, in any asset, over any time
horizon.
So this process can be repeated. And it's
really important because the numbers don't
lie.
So what we're going to be looking at is
historical volatility.
So the historical volatility of any given
market is going to tell you pretty much
what your opportunities are and what you
should expect in terms of your odds of
making certain amounts of money.
Now, when we've been through historical
volatility, what's going to happen is
Chris, Christopher Quill, who I'll
introduce you to after we've been on the
stage and gone through the presentation.
Christopher Quill, who works at the
Institute, is going to go through on his
computer how you repeat this process over
and over again.
And you shouldn't be scared of it. It's
not a difficult situation because once
you've actually learned it, you've learned
it and you can go through this process
many, many times.
So you can actually go out into the world,
download the data for any asset in the
world.
And as long as you can get that data and
you know this process, you can work out
your opportunities of making money over
any given time horizon.
So we'll go to the stage now, we'll cut
over to the stage where I'm presenting and
going through these numbers and what the
process actually looks like.
And then we're going to come back and
Chris is going to show you how to actually
go through this process so you can do it
for yourself over and over again
throughout your lifetime.
And this is really important because this
is the professional trader approach.
Data doesn't lie. Numbers don't lie. And
every professional trader knows it.
Once you've got this knowledge, it's very,
very empowering.
And professional traders will learn this
pretty much in their first year or even
couple of months when they join the
industry.
You know, I know because I've worked in
the industry, I've worked at Goldman
Sachs, I've been on their graduate
training program in New York.
And this is really what you learn when you
start out as a trader.
It's the first thing you learn.
So you guys should absolutely learn how to
go through this process so you can
understand the opportunities.
So without further ado, let's go to the
stage and I'll see you after that section
back in the office and we will go through
on Chris's computer.
Chris will show you how to do this in
Excel and using the Internet as a freely
available resources so you can do this for
the rest of your life.
Okay, so let's go through this again.
Providing a framework that allows retail
traders to emulate consistently profitable
professional traders so you can benefit
from the same approach.
Where does it all begin?
It begins with processing data.
First thing you need to do is learn the
behaviour and trends of what you're about
to trade.
Only when you do that you can begin to
understand what the potential upside and
downside is.
And generally speaking on any decent
analyst program at an investment bank
or bespoke training program at a decent
sized hedge fund.
So a decent sized hedge fund is really
only 20 employees.
This will be the first thing you're
taught.
You'll be taught the process of how to do
this.
To run distributions and work out the
odds.
And calculate the odds of making certain
amounts of money.
So you can actually probability adjust
your risk and manage your own
expectations.
And do everything correctly from the top
down.
And the numbers will speak for themselves.
Because every time you do this, the
numbers are there.
They are what they are.
And everything else is just noise.
Your job as a trader is not to argue with
the numbers.
It's to glean from the information that
you've been given by the numbers.
What's important and what's not.
So the example we used earlier was the S&P
500.
The world's largest stock market.
We're going to look at stocks again.
And look at the S&P 500.
And we're going to do a distribution of
daily returns of the S&P 500.
Going back for 50 years.
And what is the S&P 500?
It's just the average return of 500
stocks.
So the numbers for the collection of the
500 stocks are very, very similar to the
individual stocks themselves.
And you can repeat the process as many
times as you want in any of those 500
stocks.
What will happen is those numbers will be
fairly similar.
And the stocks will, the numbers will tend
towards the average.
Over a big data set.
And we've got a monster data set here.
50 years.
Where's this data from?
Did I buy it from a specialist outlet?
Did I subscribe to a website for $500 a
month?
Did I pay Bloomberg $2,000 a month?
No.
I got it from Yahoo Finance.
It's all publicly available.
The principle that we run throughout the
whole of this course is that all of this
information is publicly available.
So you don't have to rely on anything.
And you don't have to be the Japanese
corporate golfer.
So you literally go on to Yahoo Finance.
Click on S&P 500 on the homepage.
You'll be taken to the page.
Go on the left-hand side menu.
Click on historical data.
You'll be given the option for daily,
weekly, monthly, including or excluding
dividends.
Click on daily.
Click on get prices.
Scroll to the bottom of the screen.
Download to spreadsheet.
And you'll be given open, high, low, and
close.
OHLC data.
Open, high, low, close.
What are we interested in here?
We're interested in the open and the
close.
We're looking at the daily volatility of
the S&P 500 every day for 50 years, from
open to close.
So what's our window of opportunity to
make money if we buy on the open and sell
on the close?
It's a bit far-fetched to say that we buy
on the low and sell on the high.
Every day for 50 years, you'd have to be a
super trader.
It doesn't exist.
So it's a slightly more realistic
expectation.
So we've got 12,732 trading days.
From 1962 to 2012.
And we're using performance gates, as in
returns, to see what the distribution is.
And what do we get?
Well, we see from minus half a percent to
zero percent, 3,141 trading days.
From zero percent to half a percent,
3,447.
Which means what?
Between minus half a percent and plus half
a percent, half of those trading days out
of 12,732.
Roughly half.
And when you multiply through the
frequencies, you get the average return of
a down day and an up day.
As in, the average return this side and
the average return that side of zero.
That comes to 0.33% down on a down day and
0.35% up on an up day.
So up days, the market goes up slightly
more than when it goes down.
That kind of makes sense because over 50
years, the market's up.
But what if we just total up the
frequencies and say how many days is the
market down and how many days is the
market up?
Well, 47% of days, the market's down,
which means if you bought on the open and
sold on the close, 47% of times you'd have
been wrong.
And 53% of days is up.
So if you'd have shorted on the open and
bought back your short on the close, 53%
of times you'd have been wrong.
So in the last 50 years, the market's been
up thousands and thousands of percent.
But if you'd have traded every day, you
wouldn't have made money.
Because the market wasn't up 80% of days
and down 20% of days, it was pretty much
50-50, whether you were going to be right
or not when you chose your direction.
But what does the distribution actually
look like?
So who knows what a normal distribution
is?
I'm assuming that you all do.
Teaching in Cass Business School here, not
in a pub.
You should know what a normal distribution
is.
A normal distribution, a one standard
deviation, is 68% of cases, 68% of times,
yeah?
But the distribution of the stock market
is different to a normal distribution.
It's way off.
The actual distribution of the S&P 500 is
peakier around the mean, with fatter
tails.
And there's a vacuum in the middle.
Between those occurrences.
So what does that mean?
What does that tell us?
Well, standard deviation, a one standard
deviation day in the S&P 500, is 78% of
times.
So call it 80.
It means 80% of the time, a normal day,
the market moves up or down 0.35.
And 20% of times, something happens.
What happens?
The market moves.
And it usually moves quite violently, up
or down.
And there's kind of nothing in between.
Does that make sense?
So this is the behavior of the animal that
we're about to trade.
But we haven't even added in commission
yet.
That's all gross numbers.
But before we add in commission, let's
work out gross odds of making certain
amounts of money.
So if you'd have bought on the open, with
the intention of selling on the close,
every day for the last 50 years.
The probability of you making half a
percent was a 4 to 1 shot.
Against.
So 25% chance of making half a percent.
To make a percent, the odds were 9 to 1.
11% chance.
We saw that number earlier.
If you were shorting, to make half a
percent, you would have had 4.4 to 1 odds.
And to make 1%, 9.5 to 1 odds against.
So the odds of making money shorting were
slightly worse.
Which makes sense.
Because the market move up was slightly
bigger.
And it was up more days than down.
And the market was up over 50 years.
So the numbers stack up.
Yeah?
Now what happens when you add commission
in?
Well, let's do a theoretical exercise of
just working out the level of commission.
That if we pay it as our standard rate, we
can't day trade at all.
Because all our returns are lower than
zero.
Well, if you add in a commission of 0.35,
which is fairly reasonable because that's
somewhere in between an execution only
rate and an advisory rate.
Because 35.35 means 17 and a half in to
trade.
17 and a half out to trade.
It's a round trip.
If you add that in, you get wiped out in
all scenarios on a normal day.
So on a normal day, if you pay 17 and a
half basis points in, 17 and a half basis
points out, and you try day trading for
the last 50 years, you literally had zero
chance of making money.
These are the numbers.
This is the beast.
The beast has told you what it does.
It's not difficult.
And all the data is publicly available.
Back to this slide.
Now we know where we get the 0.11 from,
the 11%.
Because you've got an 11% chance when
buying the S&P 500, based on 50 years of
historical data, that you'll make 1%, i.e.
it hits your target.
So if you do the opposite of that, what
are you doing?
You're arguing with the beast.
80% of the time, the market, the beast, is
asleep.
And 20% of the time, the beast wakes up.
So if we're connecting the dots and trying
to figure out a sensible trading strategy
to make money from the beast, how do we
make money?
Well, first of all, how do we not make
money?
By day trading the beast.
Because 80% of the time, we're not going
to make money.
Only one in five days, and they don't come
every Monday or every Friday.
One in five days, we're going to get a
chance to trade and make money in one day.
Or over a short period of time.
But when you look through the past data,
those periods of volatility all occur at
the same time.
Why?
Because something big happens in the
world, where expectations change, and then
volatility goes up, and opportunities
occur.
Opportunities to make money on a
short-term basis.
That doesn't mean opportunities don't
exist full stop.
It's just the nature of the beast.
80% of the time, there's no opportunities
to make money on a one day basis.
So what have you got to do?
What have you got to do?
You've got to increase your time horizon.
So you've got to increase your time
horizon out to give yourself a chance of
making money.
To give yourself a chance, or to give the
beast a chance of allowing you to make
money.
Make sense?
Just buying or selling every day, the S&P
500, and just deciding a direction, is
literally like going to the casino.
Drunk.
So you've got two choices, you can either
walk into the casino drunk at 3am, with
all your friends, change your money for
chips, and play roulette.
And do it for the purpose of
entertainment.
Or you can go at lunchtime and count
cards, completely sober.
Who's going to win?
The opportunity to make money on a daily
basis is really widely misunderstood.
But those numbers are the numbers.
And every stock in the S&P 500, regardless
of what anybody says, over time, will tend
towards that average.
Everything else is noise.
If you're taught a day trading strategy,
the person teaching it to you, either
doesn't know this themselves, or they know
it, and they're being totally
irresponsible.
Maybe because of the conflict of interest.
Now you know these numbers, they're not
going to change.
Now you know these numbers, you know to
ask the question.
You can put these numbers in front of
anybody that gives you a day trading
strategy, who says, my day trading
strategy works.
You can put this in front of them and say,
no it doesn't, it only works 20% of the
time.
But this is why the vast majority of
retail traders just write cheques to the
market every day.
Because they're going in and buying and
selling something at the same price and
paying a commission.
It's totally, totally terminal.
And you're just going to go to zero.
What about major currency pairs?
Let's have a look at sterling US dollar
cable.
Who knows why it's called cable?
Yeah, so the copper wire that used to
connect the electric telegraph between the
UK and the US.
So sterling US dollar, the last 10 years
of data.
What do we end up with?
Well, to actually make this presentable,
we've got to reduce the parameters from
half a percent to a quarter of a percent.
Otherwise it would have looked ridiculous
on the page.
So, but you add the numbers up and you're
back again to about half the time, between
minus a quarter of a percent and a quarter
of a percent.
So 2,800 trading days and you end up with
over a thousand, 1,100 being within those
parameters.
What's the average return on an up day
relative to an average return on a down
day when multiplying through the
frequencies?
Up, 0.23, down, 0.22.
Down days, 49% of days.
Up days, 51% of days.
So the pound going up against the US
dollar or going down against the US dollar
in the last decade.
And what's the pound essentially done in
the last decade?
What's it done?
It's gone from one and a half to two.
So pound buys one and a half dollars to
pound buying two dollars.
And then it's gone from two back to one
and a half.
That's what it's done in a decade.
So it's gone up 33% and fallen 25% in 10
years.
It's not exactly very exciting, is it?
But every day, it's either up or down
50-50 chance.
What about the profile of the
distribution?
One standard deviation is 74% of times.
And relative to a normal distribution,
peakier around the mean with fatter tails.
So it has a similar profile to the stock
market, but pays less.
What are the odds of making certain
amounts of money look like in sterling US
dollar?
To make a quarter of a percent when
buying, 3.2 to 1 against.
To make half a percent, 5.6 to 1 against.
To make shorting, on a day when you decide
to short, you've got a quarter of a
percent.
A quarter of a percent, you've got 3.3 to
1 odds against.
And to make half a percent, 6 to 1
against.
And we haven't added in commission yet.
These are all gross numbers.
I hope you're not getting too depressed
about this.
You don't need to get depressed, because
it's fun.
Once you know these numbers, you're
mentally superior to 99% of people in the
market.
And then you learn to operate within that
environment and make money.
What's the level where we get wiped out on
a normal day, if we pay it?
23 basis points.
What about EURUSD?
We won't dwell on it too much.
I can tell you it's exactly the same as
sterling US dollar.
Same profile.
Same returns on a day.
Up 25, down 24.
Same profile of distribution.
72.5% of times, one standard deviation
day.
25 basis points wipes you out in all
scenarios on a normal day.
Are we excited?
Day trading currencies is even more
misunderstood and over exaggerated.
Because everybody will tell you that the
currencies markets are so liquid.
And you get a four trillion dollar market
trading per day.
Who cares?
The more liquid something is, the less
opportunities there are.
As a general rule.
Liquidity doesn't have to be...
Illiquidity doesn't have to be your enemy.
Illiquidity can be as much your friend as
your enemy.
Because if you're on the right side of
illiquidity,
everything's going to move massive in your
favour.
The whole argument that there's
opportunities in the Forex market
because it's a four trillion dollar market
and it's liquid,
is a ridiculous argument.
It doesn't matter to you.
Because actually most of that currency
that's trading every day
is just corporates hedging their currency
exposure.
They're not taking a view on the currency.
They're just hedging their exposure.
It just doesn't matter at all.
As a retail trader or even a hedge fund
manager.
It just doesn't matter.
What about leverage?
The leverage doesn't change the odds.
The odds stay exactly the same.
It just means the more leverage you use,
the quicker you're going to get wiped out.
So if you're on the other side of these
odds,
what essentially are you?
Because these odds are against.
Let's start with that.
What does it mean when you say the odds
are against?
Let's use a sporting analogy.
Let's use boxing.
Where we stick a lightweight boxer in a
boxing ring with a heavyweight boxer.
So Amir Khan and David Hay.
And you go to the casino to bet.
Who's the casino?
It's the bookmaker.
It's William Hill.
It's Ladbrokes.
It's all of these guys here.
Betfair.
They're making all the prices.
So what are they actually doing?
They're laying the odds.
They're the guys who are making the odds.
So what will the bookmaker offer you?
On Amir Khan knocking out David Hay in
round three.
What do you think they would make you at a
price?
20 to one.
You kidding me?
You'd want much higher odds than that,
wouldn't you?
You'd want thousands to one.
Or hundreds to one at least.
It's just not going to happen.
He's twice his weight.
Right?
So you're going to get really, really long
odds.
Yeah?
What odds are you going to get for David
Hay just winning the fight?
What do you think?
Evens.
Who says you would get actually better
odds?
You would probably get worse.
You'd probably end up with the inverse of
the S&P 500.
You'd probably get 11 to one on, which is
the other way around.
So you bet a dollar and you get back a
dollar and 11 cents.
Because he's odds on to win.
So what do we have to do?
What do we have to do as traders if we
know these numbers are always against us?
What do we have to do?
You have to make the odds turn in your
favor.
So every time you do something, you know
the odds are in your favor.
Make sense?
Because the bookmaker is on the other side
of these odds and they're just going to
win 90% of the time.
So you have to do the opposite to achieve
the odds to get the odds that they're
exposed to.
Yeah?
Okay, so welcome back.
I hope you managed to get your head around
that process a little bit there.
You know, this process is obviously new.
So don't get scared of it.
Once you've been through this process a
few times, you will start to really
understand the mistakes that retail
traders typically make in the instruments
that they typically trade.
Therefore, you'll start to really
understand the opposite approach, as in
the professional approach.
The approach that consistently profitable
professional traders actually do.
And I guess the numbers that you've seen
may be a little bit shocking.
So when we look at major indices and major
currency pairs, these are the instruments
that retail traders trade all the time.
And they tend to trade them on a very
short term basis.
Now, what we're simulating here by taking
the historical data and the historical
volatility distribution, what we're
simulating here is day trading.
And we're using the data from the open to
the close on a one day basis.
Now, when you look at the stock market,
the stock market, the S&P 500, it's just a
representation, the average return of an
S&P 500 stock.
So when you look at the 500 stocks in the
S&P 500, they're going to tend towards
this distribution.
So you can repeat this process in any S&P
500 stock and the numbers will be a little
bit more volatile.
But over time, they all tend towards this
central number of up or down 35 basis
points in the stock market.
And in the download section, you're going
to see numbers for other major indices.
And you'll see that they're actually very,
very similar.
So that should send you a very, very
strong message in that the 0.85, the 85%
breakeven threshold,
once you probability adjust making 1% in
the S&P 500 should start to change your
expectations as a trader.
Because what this market is essentially
telling you is that very few opportunities
occur on a one day basis.
In fact, when you look at the
distribution, we've already seen that a
normal day in the S&P 500 is 78% of times.
Which means 80% of the time, there's
pretty much no opportunity to make money
on a one day basis.
And this is very similar in major currency
pairs.
Because in major currency pairs, a normal
day is 73% of times.
Which means around three quarters of
times, there's essentially no day trading
opportunities.
Or very little day trading opportunities
in those major currency pairs.
And we're talking about the instruments
that retail traders trade all the time.
Sterling US dollar, Euro US dollar.
In the download section, you're going to
see more data for different major currency
pairs.
And you'll see that the numbers are pretty
similar across the board for all major
currency pairs.
So, when you look at this and you think,
well, my objective is to make money using
my own money and take no income from it.
Well, it very clearly shows that if you're
going into this market, and the market's
telling you what your opportunities are,
it's pretty clear that it's telling you a
few things.
Firstly, it's telling you that you can't
make income from it.
Because, secondly, and most importantly,
you can't make money from it over time.
Because all that's going to happen when
you trade these instruments on a one day
basis, is that on a normal day, the odds
are always going to be stacked against
you.
Which means, over time, your account can
only go to zero.
Your trading account can only go to zero.
Now, what's on the other side of that?
On the other side of that, is people who
are stacking the odds in their favour,
because they're increasing their time
horizon.
Now, you can repeat these processes, and
Chris is going to show you, in the next
video, how you repeat those processes on a
one day basis, on a one week basis, on a
one month basis.
It's very, very straightforward.
Don't be scared of doing it, because once
you've learned how to do it, you've
learned how to do it forever.
And this is the first thing you should be
learning, as a real trader.
Not a retail trader who loses money, a
trader who wants to make money, with their
own money, over time, and grow their
account, to become wealthier.
Now, these numbers don't change, and the
numbers speak for themselves. The market
is telling you what your opportunities
are.
You don't tell the market, how much money
you can make, over any time horizon.
When people leverage, these numbers don't
change. The market doesn't care.
So, whether you put a hundred dollars into
this trading strategy, or you put a
hundred thousand dollars, a million
dollars, or a hundred million dollars,
into this strategy, it just means one
thing.
Your account will go to zero. The market
does not care. It has no memory.
So, I think that's probably the most
shocking thing, is that when you trade on
a margin account, and you're borrowing
money to essentially trade with your own
money on margin.
Whether you put ten down, a hundred down,
or a million down, on this strategy, it's
a strategy that just doesn't work.
So, why would you put more money into it?
It doesn't make any logical sense
whatsoever.
What you have to be, is actually be on the
other side.
And, if you're going to leverage, you
should only be leveraging strategies that
actually work.
So, Chris is going to show you now, in
video number four, how you actually go
through these processes.
So, you can use Excel, and as long as you
can get the data, you can do this with any
asset, anywhere in the world, across all
the major asset classes.
So, across indices, stocks, as in equities
combined, currencies, commodities, and
rates.
You can do this for any asset, as long as
you can get the data.
So, let's go over to Chris. Chris is going
to show you how to do this on the computer
screen, in video four, so you can do this
forever, for the rest of your life.
This is going to save you a hell of a lot
of money, and it's going to lay the
foundation for you to enter strategies
where the odds are actually in your favor.
Thank you.